What do you mean?
It's decided: my life.
Decided: my job.
I can see whole other people so excited and happy to be there.
You're not afraid?
Sometimes, I feel so afraid.
That is, I can at some parts protect myself and protect my security guard and translator,...
...supporting me for my work.
And then I depend on, actually my guide.
I depend on the guide for my work.
And then, it's good.
Some parts are notorious.
Some parts have a reputation so it's good.
But it's, I love, I like; no, I love!
Being a war photographer?
My job.
I love the corps and war people.
But I don't like the war.
I believe please stop the war,...
...anywhere in the world.
My dream is that my job in the future is to be a school photographer.
A school photographer?
That's right. That is in my dream for the future.
You know the war place will be finished for the whole of the world, that scene.
And then nobody will need a photographer as a war photographer.
But and then next, I wanna be a school photographer.
That is my dream.
Wow, that's a great dream.
So, if there is no more war, that would be the perfect way to spend your life.
That's right.